[Music]
all right let's go to lucas in twin
falls what's up lucas
hey dr john how's it going man good good
good good what's up
uh hey yeah so um i'm calling you
because uh i'd like to uh get some
advice from you on how i can help my
parents get out of a very unhealthy
living situation with my older brother
uh who's 31 years old
um
yeah yeah so and uh and um i'll start
off you know this has been something
that uh
essentially transpired for the past uh
10 to 12 years um uh it all started uh
well when my older brother got into a
pretty bad legal trouble when i was in
uh
high school uh he's been in and out of
jail uh in and out of uh
treatment centers and
you know he's still living
at home and so essentially uh i've been
struggling with you know seeing my
parents uh you know letting him stay
at home without having any boundaries uh
while basically being um a very bipolar
addict and uh things are just super
super volatile
uh with them there i know
um
why is this come up now does something
happen have you suddenly just worried
about them or
have you tried things why why now
yeah yeah so so um basically i feel like
so
i feel like my relationship with my
parents is uh put is potentially uh
on a thin line just because i've just
been super frustrated uh with them just
um allowing my brother to you know
live at home and uh basically um ruin
their life you know um
my parents are both in their 60s right
now on and uh you know i feel like at
this point you can only give someone uh
so many chances um uh just to give you
some more details uh my brother
he is sick he is uh
a struggling addict um he's done pretty
much everything under the sun he's also
clinically bipolar so i just when you
mix narcotics along with uh
uh bipolar disorder uh it's not a good
thing and um
in in my recent conversations with my
family uh you know i feel like my
parents are honestly just scared of
retaliation uh from him if they try to
kick him out
it's actually not that
i'm gonna um be super truthful with you
okay
okay
your parents are getting something out
of this relationship
whether toxic whether sideways whether
what
this is feeding something for them
whether they feel some kind of guilt
over the bipolar stuff or if there's
stuff from y'all's childhood that they
are trying to
quote unquote make up for live into
or they're blaming themselves whatever
it is
they are getting something out of this
relationship
and maybe it is
safety and security because their scared
he's gonna go do something if they kick
it all that to say
is gonna be hard for you to hear
none of this is your business
what your business is is what you are
willing to tolerate relationally with
the people that you love and this is
going to be hard to hear but you have
been clear with your parents that your
brother needs professional help and that
he's probably draining them financially
he's probably has seasons when he's not
safe to be around
and they are choosing him over your
boundaries
and that leaves you to decide what you
are going to do inside of your
boundaries
so the hard answer here is there's
really nothing you can do for them
you can love them you can be kind you
can have a one more hard final with
gusto conversation
but at the end of the day they're 60
something year old adults who are making
a choice on a daily basis to live a life
for some reason
and the question is not how can i get
these 60 something year olds to change
you're not going to
you have to figure out how to be well
inside of this context and for most of
us
well in this side of context is
i'm i'm gonna go make other choices so i
can be well
you all are making your choices behavior
is a language they're choosing him
over themselves and over you
that makes sense
yeah yeah no it does it's harsh it's a
harsh way to say it i know
i know
um yeah
and here's the deal they might be
helping him with a roof that's a huge
help for an addict that's a huge help
for someone struggling with mental
health challenges but another huge help
is
high accountability and responsibility
right well and see and that's so because
first of all i totally
agree with what you said and i do
appreciate it but
that's the piece that's missing is that
um there's zero
accountability there and um you know
from what i've seen over the years and
what i've talked about with your friends
and outside family members is that um
they think they're helping him but it's
really just
enabling right lucas lucas lucas yeah
you gotta walk away
you you have you have diagnosed your
brother you've diagnosed the problem
with your parents you've diagnosed the
relational issues and what you're doing
is you're churning energy on a situation
you cannot control
it's it's uh you you probably have a
friend
who all they do all day long is watch
political news
and they come up with these crazy
theories about trade deficits and oil
prices it's because of this
literally they can control nothing
they're wasting their day they're
absolutely wasting their day you can
look at the gas pump and say man that's
terrible i'm gonna have to adjust my
budget i'm gonna have to adjust what i
buy at the store i'm gonna have to
adjust how much i drive or carpooling
that will help
but me just sitting on youtube all day
trying to come up with solutions for
problems that see what i'm saying like
it becomes this futile spinning and
spinning and spinning
and that's where you are man
and what it's doing at the end of the
day it's an affirmative choice to take
joy and beauty and peace out of your
life trying to solve another problem
you're gonna have to grieve it it's
gonna suck
right but you haven't dropped your
shoulders and just said this is the way
this is this is how my parents are
choosing to live
and when you know you're right when you
do that
it's gonna hurt man
because you're gonna miss your parents
you're gonna miss your brother
and then you're gonna have to do the
hard work of seeking to not spend spin
your wheels trying to solve a problem
you can't solve
but in seeking joy and finding peace and
finding laughter and finding community
and finding friends to meet some of
those needs that you hope that your
parents would meet but they're not
meeting them because they're too hung up
on their other situation
yeah
okay so then so then that said what's
your advice on um
setting boundaries within the
relationship with my parents and then
you know deciding whether or not i want
to
go go back home for the holidays and all
that because great as as you know you
know when
when you have um
yes when you have a private son in your
family you know that tends to be the
topic of most of the conversations yeah
you know
all this is already hard enough for uh
with people but
you know when you have something like
this there's just that other looming
elephant um in in the room so what's
your advice on
you know
setting boundaries for myself for my own
mental sanity and and
mental health uh by the way um
i actually started going to therapy for
many reasons last year but uh this was
actually one of them was just kind of
coping with this
whole thing good for you for taking
affirmative steps
ultimately it's this
you deciding
forget the consequences
decide what you're worth
and decide your value and decide what
you'll tolerate and what you won't
and it may come down to a conversation
like this
i love you mom and dad with all my heart
i can no longer be a participant in a
relationship where i'm watching somebody
hurt my parents over and over and over
and
i will not talk about my brother anymore
and so
if he's gonna be there during
thanksgiving or christmas
i'm gonna choose to not go
and so you're not doing ultimatums
you're not threatening
you are making grown-up choices with
your grown-up finances and your grown-up
choice-making abilities
they can then make grown-up choices on
their own
on whether we're gonna have to ask
brother to leave because we want lucas
to come home
or we're gonna talk bad about lucas and
make him feel guilty and make him feel
really bad for have her not caring about
his brother and for leaving his parents
high in dr that's their grown-up choices
to make how they respond you cannot
control that and the more you hem in
your needs
to try to make somebody else feel less
awkward
the
the the further from an authentic core
you get
the crazier you'll feel
and most of us feel crazy by getting
pissed off we get angry
yeah right and then we get angry we
start trying to blame and solve and
that's a whole cat look at our culture
that's us right
yeah yeah no no i mean you're right and
um yeah or telling your brother
i will not come to mom and dad's house
if you're still there
it's time for you to check into a rehab
facility and it's time for you to get
clean and if you're not great i am going
gonna choose to not be a part of this
dysfunction
and when you hang up the phone you may
have dude you may have a hole in your
gut
you may weep for hours
and the follow-up phone calls and texts
and letters may be caustic and mean you
may have to get to where you block your
parents from texting you
because they're going to send these long
talk to text texts right that are so
dramatic and so long
i cannot control
the response of other adults to my needs
and you might have to do the really hard
work of finding a new gang to do
thanksgiving with or a new gang to do
christmas with
and it might be the first peaceful
holiday season you've had in a long long
time
yeah yeah well i can say so i've been
married for a little over three years
and uh once i got married it's basically
been holidays i've been with uh with my
in-laws and it's been a lot better there
you go you know you have a new you have
a new picture right you have another
picture oh family can look like this i
thought it just looked like that yeah
this could look way different right and
that's fantastic that's wonderful
i want you to mourn this like
trying to think
somewhere inside
there is a picture you had
of when you have your first little one
and or of the
how your parents were gonna welcome in
your wife and we're gonna hug hug hug
hug hug and it's gonna be this big
dramatic thing and they were gonna be
best friends and your brother was gonna
clean up
and at some point you have to have
a you have to grieve it you have to have
a funeral if you will
for that picture it's not gonna happen
or at least not gonna happen anytime
soon
yeah and once we do that then we can
begin to deal with reality which is
probably not gonna do christmas and
holidays there not a safe place for me
and my family
and that's awful i hate that
maybe one day two years later five years
later six years later
mom and dad make some pretty dramatic
changes brother gets clean they decide
to hold him accountable they decide well
we're gonna have nothing right this
might mean you're out of the will or
you're not gonna be
get uh inheritance what
great man these are about you're this is
about you being well and living a
peaceful joyful life you see what i'm
saying
yeah ultimately i'm sure it's about
reclaiming control
that you've outsourced to them
because you're waiting for them to make
the quote-unquote right choices and
decisions so that you can feel better
and that's never going to work that way
yeah no number one you're right um
i hate that man i feel like i'm like
though like i feel like it's like hey
here's a balloon i'm like let me pop it
yeah yeah no no i mean i mean i was the
one uh uh who called so um i asked for
it you know
so yeah you called me bro
no yeah here's what i really want i want
you to have a holiday season where you
laugh really hard for your guts
and you get a few days off of work and
you sleep like you're in a black hole
you wake up refreshed and you have a
breakfast that's a little bit bigger
than you should probably have and y'all
go for a walk when it's freezing cold
outside and you're miserable but it's
kind of awesome
like
not worrying about mom and dad's
finances and their choices and what is
there some other way i can say it or
there's some other way i can manipulate
it or something i can do for
just set that stuff down man
yeah set it down
see what i'm saying i hate this for you
dude i really do i wish your brother
would um
have some clarity and i wish some people
in his life that were really close to
him would hold him to some high
accountability and help him get the care
that he needs
instead of
just giving him a free pass because it's
not helping him right you know that
um
we're just not there yet
but yeah if your parents are ever not
safe of course call the police um you
can get involved that way
um
you can write them the final letter you
can just be pretty open about your
boundaries or you can just let it kind
of fade right you can just let it kind
of fade and not call as much or not text
and just begin to work on the things you
can control which are the relationships
that uh people who are willing to uh
reciprocate right and they may reach out
in a month or two months or three months
and say hey i haven't heard from you in
a while and you can say hey it's great
to hear from you and go about your day
and um
just slowly let things fade
and if they ever call you on it you can
say yeah i made some pretty conscious
choices to
not watch you guys get hurt anymore and
would not watch brother get get hurt
anymore because he's not getting the
care that he needs and i just chose to
step out and control what i can control
and um man
it's hard hard road ahead of you and
it's also a right road
and my hope is there's some
reconciliation in your family my brother
i hope so